I'm Jenna Fisher. And I'm Angela Kinsey. We were on The Office together. And we're best friends. And now we're doing the Ultimate Office rewatch podcast just for you. Each week we will break down an episode of The Office and give exclusive behind-the-scenes stories that only two people who were there can tell you. We're The Office, ladies. Hello. Hi there. This is Season 7, Episode 18, Todd Packer. I mean, it's pretty cool if your character gets its own episode. Like, I would have loved an episode called Angela Martin. You're so right. Right? Pam Beasley. Kaboom. Well, this is Todd Packer. Yeah, it is. It was written by Amelie Gillette, directed by Randall Einhorn. Here's your summary. The
我是珍娜·费舍。我是安吉拉·金西。我们一起出演过《办公室》。而且我们是最好的朋友。现在我们专门为你制作了《办公室》终极重温播客。每周我们都会剖析一集《办公室》，并提供只有当时身临其境的两个人才能告诉你的独家幕后故事。我们是《办公室》女郎。大家好。嗨。这是第七季第十八集，托德·帕克。我的意思是，如果你的角色能有一集以他命名，那就太酷了。比如，我会很想要一集叫安吉拉·马丁的。你说的太对了。对吧？帕姆·比斯利。轰。好吧，这就是托德·帕克。是的，确实是。由阿梅莉·吉莱特编剧，兰德尔·因霍恩执导。以下是剧情梗概。
gang is upset when traveling salesman Todd Packer has offered a permanent sales position in The Office. It causes such contempt that Dwight and Jim joined forces to oust him. Meanwhile, Andy really, really wants a new computer. I mean, yeah. Real bad. He is very envious that Pam bought a new one for the reception desk. Before we jump into fast facts, I just have to share something with everyone. What is it? Jenna was the first person here today at Ear Wolf, and apparently she found the thermostat because it was pretty chilly today. And Jenna cranked it. I mean, is it too warm? It's bawling in here. Like, my glass has a little bit of like a frosty side. I'm loving it. I feel like when you go to
当旅行推销员托德·帕克在办公室获得一个永久销售职位时，大家都很沮丧。这引发了极大的蔑视，以至于德怀特和吉姆联手将他赶走。与此同时，安迪非常非常想要一台新电脑。我是说，真的。非常糟糕。他非常嫉妒帕姆为前台买了一台新电脑。在我们跳进快讯之前，我必须和大家分享一件事。是什么事？珍娜是今天第一个来到Ear Wolf的人，显然她找到了恒温器，因为今天挺冷的。而且珍娜把温度调高了。我是说，是不是太暖和了？里面简直像个火炉。我的杯子旁边甚至结了一层薄霜。我喜欢这样。我觉得当你去
a restaurant and they're like, don't worry. We have a heat lamp on the patio, and then they sit you right under it, and you're like, oh, should we turn it down? I can't believe I'm saying that. I can't believe it. It feels like when you go into like a movie and it's so warm, you go, well, I'll be sleeping through this. Oh, no. Oh, no, I'm sorry. I was so cold when I got here. This is going to be sleepy Todd Packer. Anyway, let's get into some fast facts. Fast fact number one, this episode aired on February 24th, 2011. And this is the first script by new writer Amelie Gillette. Before joining the office, she worked for the online magazine, the AV club. And each week they wrote a review of our office episodes
一家餐厅，他们说，别担心。我们在露台上有个加热灯，然后他们把你安排在它正下方，你会想，哦，我们应该把它调小一点吗？我不敢相信我在这么说。我真不敢相信。这感觉就像你去看电影，里面热得不行，你会想，好吧，我会一路睡过去。哦，不。哦，不，我很抱歉。我来的时候太冷了。这将是昏昏欲睡的托德·帕克。不管怎样，让我们进入快讯。快讯一，本集于2011年2月24日播出。这是新编剧阿梅莉·吉莱特的第一个剧本。在加入《办公室》之前，她曾为网络杂志《影音俱乐部》工作。每周他们都会对我们的《办公室》剧集进行评价
after they aired live. Did she have to write her own review? No. Also when she worked there, she did not write the reviews, but she did write an article about the 2007 office convention. And when Amelie joined the office, the AV club put this little note on their website that I thought was really charming. Okay, here's what it says. In case you haven't heard, big ups are due to the lovely and talented Ms. Amelie Gillette who will be joining the writing staff of the office. Any of our TV club regulars will tell you they have no intention of giving the show higher ratings just to suck up to her and maybe get a television writing gig of their own. They'll tell you that, but I won't. I preemptively declare all Amelie
在它们现场播出之后。她必须写自己的评论吗？不用。还有，当她在那里工作时，她没有写评论，但她确实写了一篇关于2007年《办公室》大会的文章。当阿梅莉加入《办公室》时，影音俱乐部在他们的网站上发布了一条小短信，我觉得非常迷人。好吧，它是这么说的。如果你还没听说过，必须对可爱且有才华的阿梅莉·吉莱特女士致以崇高的敬意，她将加入《办公室》的编剧团队。我们的任何电视俱乐部常客都会告诉你，他们绝无意为了拍她的马屁并通过她可能给自己谋得一个电视编剧职位而给该剧打更高的高分。他们会这么说，但我不会。我先发制人地宣布所有阿梅莉
Gillette episodes of the office to be an A plus rating or higher. And then they went on to say, long time readers also know that Nathan Rabine has traditionally covered the office for TV club. You'll also notice he's not anymore. We felt that anyone who is friends with Amelie should no longer write about the show. So we've brought in TV critic scholar and office fan Myles McNutt, who we're sure will do an excellent job and never be friend Amelie. He had to stay unbiased. Yes. Yeah. Please welcome him and keep your comment section hazing to a minimum. So Myles McNutt did write a review of Todd Packer. Okay. He gave it a B minus. Okay. He really liked Jim and Dwight banding together. He liked
吉莱特编写的《办公室》剧集评级都是A加或更高。然后他们继续说道，老读者也知道内森·拉宾传统上一直负责电视俱乐部的《办公室》报道。你还会注意到他不再负责了。我们觉得任何与阿梅莉是朋友的人都不应该再撰写关于该剧的评论。所以我们请来了电视评论家、学者兼《办公室》粉丝迈尔斯·麦克纳特，我们确信他会做得非常出色，而且绝不会和阿梅莉交朋友。他必须保持公正。是的。是的。请欢迎他，并把你们评论区的霸凌行为降到最低。所以迈尔斯·麦克纳特确实写了一篇关于托德·帕克的评论。好吧。他给它打了B减。好吧。他真的很喜欢吉姆和德怀特联手。他喜欢
the Kevin storyline. He liked Pam and Andy and all of that. He basically liked the episode. I mean, I read the review, but here's the thing. Why the B minus? Yeah, he doesn't like Todd Packer. Oh, well, then that's a tough episode to review. If Todd Packer is your least favorite character. Yeah, he literally said he doesn't like Todd Packer or any episodes that feature his character B minus. Oh, well, there was more of Todd Packer in the shooting draft. Oh, no, you might have gotten a C. I'm going to share it today. Myles, you might not like this podcast episode if we share more Todd Packer. Yeah. Well, if you're looking for more Dave Kekner, I can help you out with fast fact number two. Okay. Dave Kekner,
凯文的故事情节。他喜欢帕姆、安迪以及所有这些。他基本上挺喜欢这一集的。我是说，我读过这篇评论，但问题是。为什么是B减？对，他不喜欢托德·帕克。哦，那这一集对评论来说可真够难评的。如果托德·帕克是你最不喜欢的角色。是的，他 literalmente 说过他不喜欢托德·帕克或任何以他的角色为主角的剧集，所以B减。哦，拍摄初稿里其实有更多托德·帕克的戏份。哦，不，你可能会得个C。我今天要分享出来。迈尔斯，如果我们分享更多托德·帕克的戏份，你可能会不喜欢这一集的播客。好吧。如果你想了解更多关于戴夫·凯克纳的事，我可以帮你介绍快讯二。好吧。戴夫·凯克纳，
of course, played Todd Packer. Oh, yes. Thank you, Angela. This is a fan question from LAS in Washington who said, I believe the actor who played Todd Packer auditioned first to play Michael Scott. Did he get a callback for this side character because he was such a good actor? Well, LA, you are correct. He did originally audition for the role of Michael Scott. Dave was at a fan expo in Boston and he spoke about auditioning for Michael Scott and also about the fact that he was not even the original Todd Packer. Oh, yeah. I remember that. I had auditioned for the office, but they were using the same pilot episode from the British office and just changed some American references. I was a huge fan of the British
当然，饰演了托德·帕克。哦，是的。谢谢你，安吉拉。这是一个来自华盛顿的LAS的粉丝提问，他问，我相信饰演托德·帕克的演员最初是去试镜迈克尔·斯科特的。他因为是个这么好的演员才得到了这个小角色的回电吗？好吧，LA，你猜对了。他最初确实为迈克尔·斯科特这个角色进行了试镜。戴夫在波士顿的一个粉丝见面会上谈到了为迈克尔·斯科特试镜的事，还谈到了他甚至不是最初的托德·帕克的事。哦，对。我记得那个。我曾为《办公室》试镜，但他们用的是英国版《办公室》的同一集试镜剧集，只是改动了一些美国本地的梗。我是英国版
version of the office. So when I'm reading from Michael's part, I can't get past Ricky Gervais way he did it. Like I can't think of anything else. So I didn't get it, obviously. So then I went on to work on something else. They were on episode three of the first season. They had hired an actor and it just wasn't working. So they went on and they started shooting the fourth episode thinking we'll go back to this. I didn't audition for that part because I was out of town shooting snakes on a plane. You're welcome. So I get back to town. I've known Steve Carell since 1990. I get back to town and Steve tells to Greg Daniels, why not Keckner? Well, there's a million reasons why not, but they ignored
《办公室》的超级粉丝。所以当我朗读迈尔斯的台词时，我无法摆脱瑞奇·热维斯那种表演方式。就像我脑子里想不出别的。所以我当然没拿到那个角色。然后我去拍别的东西了。他们当时在拍第一季的第三集。他们雇了一个演员，但效果就是不太好。所以他们继续拍了第四集，心想我们以后再回过头来看这个。我没有为那个角色试镜，因为我当时不在城里，在拍《航班蛇患》。不客气。所以我回到了城里。我从1990年起就认识史蒂夫·卡瑞尔了。我回到城里，史蒂夫对格雷格·丹尼尔斯说，为什么不找凯克纳呢？好吧，有成千上万个不该找他的理由，但他们忽略了
all of those and hired me anyway. But something like that is in my wheelhouse. It's very easy for me to play and I love it. If you think about it, Todd Packer is like you're invited to someone's very nice house. They've drawn you a nice bath and you get in that bathtub and you splash out all the water. You dirty all their towels and walk out naked where they're having a children's party in the house. That's what it's like to play Todd Packer. I could hear Kate Flannery's laugh. Kate Flannery was on the stage with him. Yeah. Yeah. So Angela, I think something we haven't talked about before is that there was an actor cast in the role of Todd Packer. Yeah. We shot for a couple days with him in the first season
所有这些，最后还是雇了我。但类似这样的角色很适合我。对我来说演起来很简单，而且我很喜欢。如果你想想看，托德·帕克就像是你被邀请去某人家非常漂亮的房子。他们为你放了一缸舒服的热水，你坐进那个浴缸里，把水全泼了出去。你弄脏了他们所有的毛巾，然后光着身子走出来，而他们家里正在开儿童派对。这就是扮演托德·帕克的感受。我能听到凯特·弗兰内里的笑声。凯特·弗兰内利当时和他同台。对。对。所以安吉拉，我觉得我们以前没聊过的一点是，曾经有一个演员被选中出演托德·帕克。对。我们在第一季和他一起拍了几天戏
and it just was not clicking. Right. And they recast him with Dave Keckner. And now he's got a whole episode. I know he has a whole episode. And the minute to Dave's credit, the minute he walked on stage, he was Todd Packer. We were like, oh my God. It's like you knew Rain would be Dwight. Yes. You knew Dave Keckner would be Todd Packer. Well, moving on to Fast Fact number three, I've got a little nerdy production speak coming your way. I love it. I love it when you geek out. Randy Cordray told me that this episode was a bottle show. The name of this is called bottle show. Look how tickled you are. Just saying bottle show. You're so tickled. Tell us what a bottle show is. A bottle show is
，但就是擦不出火花。对。然后他们重新选了戴夫·凯克纳。现在他有一整集都是他的戏份。我知道他有一整集。而且说真的，戴夫一上台，他就是托德·帕克。我们当时想，哦天哪。就像你知道雷恩会是德怀特一样。是的。你知道戴夫·凯克纳会是托德·帕克。好吧，我们进入快讯三，我有一些关于制作方面的专业术语要带给你。我喜欢。我喜欢你化身技术宅的样子。兰迪·科德雷告诉我这一集是一部“瓶装剧”。这个名字叫“瓶装剧”。看你高兴的。光是说“瓶装剧”三个字。你太高兴了。给我们解释一下什么是瓶装剧吧。瓶装剧是
a Hollywood television term for an episode that basically stays within its established sets. It doesn't have very many guest roles. It has very minimal stunts, minimal special effects, minimal visual effects. They are the least expensive episodes to produce in a season. Did we have to have so many bottle episodes a season for our budget? Yes, Angela. Randy explained the budget process to me, which again, I was geeking out. He said that the studio gave us a master budget each season. And it was a huge number. And he had to allocate it for the whole year for each episode. Yeah. He would have to meet with our production accountant who was named Carolyn Hayes. I remember Carolyn. Yes. And our UPM, Steve
一个好莱坞电视术语，指的是基本上只在既定布景内拍摄的一集。它没有太多的客串角色。它的特技极少，特效极少，视觉效果极少。它们是一季中制作成本最低的剧集。为了预算，我们每一季都得拍那么多瓶装剧吗？是的，安吉拉。兰迪向我解释了预算流程，我当时又开始化身技术宅了。他说工作室每一季都会给我们一个总预算。那是一个庞大的数字。他必须把这笔钱分配给整年里的每一集。是的。他得和我们的制作会计师开会，她叫卡洛琳·海斯。我记得卡洛琳。是的。还有我们的UPM，史蒂夫
Burgess and Randy, they would all sit down together and they would have to divide the budget into all the different categories that they had to pay for for a particular episode. And that included salaries for all the cast and crew, writers, directors, rentals, editing, voice production, literally everything. Locations, props, music, all of it. That sounds so intimidating to me. That is like that. If a train left at 3pm, like equation, no, please don't make me do that. So they would have a discussion with the writers to get sort of a general idea of what the season was going to be like, but they had to set this budget not really knowing any scripts specifically. How do you do that? He said, you just do your best.
伯吉斯和兰迪，他们会坐在一起，必须把预算划分到他们必须为特定一集支付的所有不同类别中。这包括所有演员和剧组人员的薪水、编剧、导演、租金、剪辑、声音制作，字面意义上的所有东西。外景、道具、音乐，全都有。这听起来对我有种极强的威慑感。这就像如果一辆火车在下午3点出发这种方程式，不，请别让我做这种事。所以他们会与编剧讨论，对这一季的大致走向有个基本概念，但他们必须在完全不知道任何具体剧本的情况下设定这个预算。这怎么做得到？他说，你只能尽力而为。
And not all episodes end up costing the same. Some of them went way over the per episode budget. Examples of those this season would be threat level midnight, Andy's play and the search. And in order to balance the books, the writers would have to include a certain number of bottle shows. And here's one of your bottle shows. I feel like Carolyn and Randy and Steve Burgess would all be really good at that price is right game where you have to guess the item. For sure. Well, lady, that's all I got. We could go to a break and then when we come back, we have a very interesting cold open with the most disgusting sounds. If you just listen to the cold open, it'll make you gag. Oh, I didn't even think of that.
而且并不是每一集的成本都一样。其中一些剧集的单集预算超支非常严重。这一季的例子有《午夜威胁》、《安迪的戏剧》和《搜寻》。为了平衡账目，编剧们必须加入一定数量的瓶装剧。这就是其中一集瓶装剧。我觉得卡洛琳、兰迪和史蒂夫·伯吉斯去玩那个需要猜商品价格的《价格猜猜猜》节目一定会非常厉害。那是肯定的。好吧，各位，我只有这些了。我们可以进入广告时间，等我们回来后，将会有一个非常有趣的冷开场，里面包含最恶心的声音。如果你只听这个冷开场，都会让你作呕。哦，我甚至都没想到这一点。
We'll be back. We're back. And that slurping noise you hear is Dwight having to eat all the canned foods that would have been in his bunker that might expire. It's so many things. It's like canned tomatoes and canned mackerel and some kind of thing that looks like just really slimy okra. I don't even know. All of it is just slimy and then some kind of gelatinous liquid. You know, I hoarded a bunch of food down in my basement. How'd that go? You know, it's kind of great because sometimes you go down there and you find a real treasure. But there was one night when I can't remember what happened, but the kids were off doing something and Lee was off doing something and I didn't
我们马上回来。我们回来了。你听到的那种啧啧的吸吮声是德怀特不得不吃掉他地堡里所有可能过期的罐头食品。东西太多了。比如罐头西红柿、罐头鲭鱼，还有某种看起来就像非常黏糊的秋葵一样的东西。我甚至不知道。全都是黏糊糊的，然后还有某种胶状的液体。你知道，我在地下室囤了一堆食物。结果怎么样？你知道，这其实挺棒的，因为有时你走下去，能找到真正的宝藏。但有天晚上，我不记得发生了什么，孩子们在外面做什么，李也在外面做什么，我没有
have time to go to the grocery store and I thought, I'm just going to go to the basement and see what we got. And all we had left was some expired pasta sauce. But I was like, how bad could it be? Right? So I made some pasta and then I made the mistake of not tasting the pasta sauce first, doused my pasta, the last of the pasta in the sauce. It had turned. Yeah. It was awful. And I can't even remember what I had for dinner that night, but after that I was kind of like done. So I do admire Dwight for keeping his eye on the expiration dates. Personal question for you. Yeah. Would you be someone who would have a bunker? Why are you asking me that? Of course. It's my dream. It's, I daydream
时间去杂货店，我想，我干脆去地下室看看我们有什么。我们剩下的只有一些过期的意面酱。但我想，能有多糟呢？对吧？所以我做了一些意面，然后我犯了个错误，没有先尝尝意面酱的味道，就把意面全倒了进去，把最后剩下的意面拌进酱里。它已经变质了。是的。太糟糕了。我甚至不记得那天晚上我吃的是什么晚饭了，但从那以后我基本上就对这事死心了。所以我很佩服德怀特能时刻盯着保质期。问你一个私人的问题。好吧。你会是那种拥有地堡的人吗？你为什么问我这个？当然。这是我的梦想。我做梦
about it. You daydream about your bunker. I love it. Do you remember the bunker in the movie Grease 2? No, I don't want to go make out in. Ever since I saw that movie in my youth, I've wanted one. I don't even know if I've ever seen Grease 2. What? Is that the Michelle Pfeiffer? I'm a smooth rider? Michelle Pfeiffer? I don't know if I've seen it all the way through. The bowling alley dance? I don't even know what you're talking about. Oh my God. What's the bowling alley dance? I can't. I don't even know if I can keep talking to you right now. All right. It's so good. But yes, Angela, of course I want a bunker. Have you met me? Do you want one? I mean, if it would make
都在想它。你做梦都在想你的地堡。我太喜欢了。你还记得电影《油脂2》里的那个地堡吗？不，我可不想去里面亲热。自从我年轻时看过那部电影以来，我就一直想要一个。我都不知道我有没有完整看过《油脂2》。什么？那是米歇尔·菲佛演的吗？我是个潇洒骑手？米歇尔·菲佛？我不知道我有没有从头到尾看过。保龄球馆的那段舞蹈？我甚至不知道你在说什么。哦天哪。什么是保龄球馆的舞蹈？我真的不行。我甚至不知道现在还能不能继续跟你聊天。好吧。太棒了。但是是的，安吉拉，我当然想要一个地堡。你认识我吗？你想要一个吗？我是说，如果它能
you feel better, here's the thing. I don't need everybody to have a bunker. I just want one. Do you want one? If the shit is really going to hit the fan that hard. Yeah. That you're going to go have to live in your bunker. What is the world you're coming out the door to? I don't know, but I'm not sticking around for the zombies. I'm not sticking around for the zombies. I'm coming out to see what it is. I'm not sticking around for them. When it all goes down, I'm going to be like, you know what? I'm making margaritas and I'm going to watch the fireworks. Hmm. Yeah. It would be depressing to live in the bunker for like a month and then you come up and there's no oxygen. Yeah. I mean, that would
让你感觉好点的话，问题是这样的。我不需要每个人都有地堡。我只是自己想要一个。你想要一个吗？如果世界末日真的来得那么猛烈。是的。以至于你不得不搬进地堡里生活。当你走出房门时，外面是个怎样的世界？我不知道，但我可不会留下来面对丧尸。我可不留下来面对丧尸。我要出去看看外面是什么样。我才不会陪它们呢。当这一切真的发生时，我会想，你知道吗？我要做玛格丽塔酒，然后去看烟花。嗯。是的。如果在地堡里生活一个月，然后上来发现连氧气都没有了，那也太沮丧了吧。是的。我是说，那可真是太逊了。我只是说说而已。是的。我可能只会喝点玛格丽塔酒凑合着度过。嗯，我懂你的意思。其实我也想要一个。所以，我在这方面也有点像德怀特。当德怀特吃着他那些黏糊糊、吸溜吸溜的食物时，他把所有人都恶心到了，连凯文都受不了。是的。他们都在干呕。德怀特有一段精彩的台词，他说，你知道吗？你们可以笑话我，但当灾难降临时，别来敲我避难所的门求我。然后他告诉他们所有人如果灾难降临会有什么下场。我最喜欢的部分是他说，梅雷迪思，你会没事的。我懂。所以听着，我们收到了关于这个冷开场的大量粉丝来信。是因为我在闲聊里提过吗？是的。我一直在等这个。好吧，来自田纳西州的贝丝S
really be shitty. I'm just saying. Yeah. I might just ride it out with some margaritas. Um, I hear you. I also do want it. So I'm, I'm a little Dwight here. As Dwight eats all of his slimy, slurpy food, he grosses everyone out, even Kevin. Yeah. They're like gagging. Dwight has this great speech where he says, you know what? You can laugh at me, but when disaster strikes, don't come knocking and begging at my shelter door. And then he tells them all what would happen to them. And my favorite part is when he's like, Meredith, you'll be okay. I know. So listen, we got a fan mail flurry about this cold open. Was it because I talked about it in the chump? Yes. I was waiting for this. All right. Beth S from Tennessee
说，在这个冷开场里，帕姆穿着一件夹克。这是因为这是前不久拍的吗？我想我记得安吉拉说过它在之前的剧本里。是的。来自纽约市的香农M说，这就是你们在闲聊里谈论过的那个冷开场。它真的存在。是的，伙计们。这个场景原本是在第六季《闲聊》拍摄期间撰写并拍摄的。它甚至还被收录在第六季的NG镜头里。安吉拉谈到过这个，但我们没有播放那个片段。我想也许我们应该放一下。哦，对。真的很好笑。是的。所以当德怀特列举出所有会发生在我们身上的事因为他拒绝在未来帮助我们时，本来应该还有一个额外的桥段，那就是克里德说，那我呢？是的。然后他告诉克里德他的头骨会被用来做什么。太搞笑了。是的。而且我们当时根本拍不下去。我觉得它不在正片里，因为我不觉得我们拍出过任何一条能用的。听听这段NG吧。我能做什么？你的头骨将会。我能做什么？你的头骨将会被做成汤碗。我能做什么？你的头骨将会被做成汤碗。我能做什么？我能做什么？你的头骨会变成一个汤碗。太酷了。拍了那么多遍。我们从来没拍顺过。拍了那么多遍。而且，如果你仔细看，雷恩在努力吃那些稀里糊涂的食物，他极力忍住不笑。所以这就是为什么他一直在那儿。我们最后总算拍过了一条。还有约翰，镜头拍到他的肩膀，其实只有他的肩膀。那是克里德的
said, in this cold open, Pam is wearing a jacket. Is this because this was filmed a while back? I think I remember Angela talking about it being in a previous script. Yes. And Shannon M from New York City said, this is the cold open that you guys talked about in the chump. It exists. Yes, guys. This scene was originally scripted and shot during season six, the chump. It was even featured on the season six bloopers. Angela talked about that, but we didn't play the clip. And I think maybe we should. Oh yeah. It's really funny. Yeah. So when Dwight is listing all the things that would happen to us because he refuses to help us in the future, there was supposed to be an extra beat where Creed says, what about
脸越过了约翰的肩膀。但你能看到约翰的肩膀。他在抖动，因为他笑得太厉害了。约翰笑得太厉害了。而雷恩把那些东西全吃下去了。天哪，他吃了那么多。这一集将从托德·帕克回到斯克兰顿开始。你想知道他为什么决定不再到处跑了吗？请告诉我。因为，用托德·帕克的话说，好吧，事实是，我这鸟儿上长了几个情欲疙瘩。所以游戏结束了。是的。迈克尔欣喜若狂。他太高兴了。他想让托德·帕克回来。但这需要霍莉的批准。我想她必须盖章同意才行。而托德开启了魅力攻势。他说，对不起。我还以为我要见的是霍莉，而不是詹妮弗·安妮斯顿。
me? Yeah. And then he tells Creed what he'd use his skull for. It's so funny. Yeah. And we could not get through it. I don't think it's in the episode because I don't think we ever got a take of it. Let's hear the blooper. What can I do? Your skull will be. What can I do? Your skull will be made of soup ball. What can I do? Your skull will be made of soup ball. What can I do? What can I do? Your skull will be a soup ball. Cool. So many times. We never got it. So many times. Also, like if you watch it, Rain is trying to eat the sloppy stuff and he's trying not to laugh. So that's why he's going. And we did finally get through one. And John, whose shoulders, it's just his shoulders. It's Creed's
霍莉被迷住了。这个场景在拍摄初稿中要更长一些。托德和霍莉在那个会议室里多了一段交流。哦，我想听听这个。好的。拍摄初稿里是这么写的。内景，会议室，霍莉和帕克坐在一起。帕克表现得极为规矩。迈克尔在外面踱步。场景开始时，托德试图用他对音乐的热爱以及他最喜欢的音乐家是谁来吸引霍莉。并将这位音乐家的歌曲和歌词与斯克兰顿对他的意义进行某种比较。你必须听听这个。你还有什么问题要问我吗？没有。我只想补充最后一点。我在路上花了很多时间听音乐。我最喜欢的艺术家之一是约翰·库格尔
face over John's shoulder. But you can see John's shoulders. He's doing a shimmy because he's laughing so hard. John was laughing so hard. And Rain ate through all of that. God, he ate so much. The episode is going to start with Todd Packer being back and Scranton. You want to know why he's decided to get off the road? Please tell me. It's because, to quote Todd Packer, all right, truth is, I got a couple of love bumps on my ding dong. So game over. Yeah. Michael is thrilled. He's so happy. He wants Todd Packer back. But it's going to need the approval of Holly. I guess she has to rubber stamp this. And Todd turns on the charm. He's like, I'm sorry. I thought I was meeting Holly, not Jennifer Aniston.
·梅伦坎普。他歌唱家乡的重要性。霍莉，这就是我的家乡。而这个分公司就是我的小粉红房子。是的。哇。然后她说，好吧，你们的业绩说明了一切。迈克尔喜欢你。你被录用了。我对此无言以对。我知道。那真的是非常精彩的写作。当我看到它时，有一个时刻我想，等等，托德·帕克，他怎么变得有点平易近人了？是的。这是怎么回事？好吧，迈克尔要向办公大楼里的员工宣布这个消息。托德·帕克回来了。他将成为一名正式的销售员。在第3分钟22秒，我记下了菲利斯标志性的双重白眼。不，是帕姆和安吉拉。你们没看见我们吗？镜头从我切到你。我
Holly is charmed. This scene was longer in the shooting draft. Todd and Holly had an extra beat in that conference room. Oh, I want to hear this. Okay. This is how it read in the shooting draft. Interior conference room, Holly and Packer sit together. Packer is on his best behavior. Michael paces outside. The scene opens with Todd trying to charm Holly about his love of music and who his favorite musician is. And he compares sort of this musician's songs and lyrics to what Scranton means to him. You have to hear it. Do you have any more questions for me? No. I just want to add one last thing. I spent a lot of time on the road listening to music. And one of my favorite artists is John Cougar
笑出声来，因为我觉得我以前和你一起去过晚宴或其他活动，当我们遇到现实生活中的那种托德·帕克时，我们也会互相递出那种眼神。是的，我很喜欢那个。我很喜欢。然后镜头又切到了菲利斯，她看起来就像闻到了一个屁。我没注意到那个。我还一直在为我们的双重白眼笑呢。艾伦和盖布迟到了。我猜盖布在淋浴时摔倒了。随着这些剧集的播出，盖布被写得越来越荒谬了。确实如此。好吧，当艾伦到达时，她看到桌上摆着一台崭新的电脑，非常兴奋。那是一个巨大的显示器。我们收到了来自温尼伯的艾米M的粉丝提问。自从我自己开始在办公室工作以来，
Mellon Camp. He sings about the importance of hometowns. Holly, this is my hometown. And this branch is my little pink house. Yeah. Wow. Then she's like, well, yourselves speak for themselves. Michael loves you. You got the job. I'm speechless over that. I know. That was really brilliant writing. And when I watched it, it had this moment where I was like, wait, Todd Packer, he's kind of being relatable. Yeah. What's happening? Well, Michael is going to introduce this news to the bullpen. Todd Packer is back. He's going to be a permanent salesman. At three minutes, 22 seconds, I wrote down double sneer from Phyllis. No, from Pam and Angela. Did you not see us? It goes from me to you. And I
一直让我感到困扰的是，当办公室里其他人都用PC时，帕姆却给艾伦买了一台iMac。如果他们有任何形式的共享系统，从IT的角度来看这根本说不通。这是苹果的付费植入广告吗？这个点抓得太好了。这就像你家里的那种人，当每个人都有iPhone时，他们偏要用安卓，然后你尝试发送图片和视频，结果它们全都是压缩得像屎一样的小碎片。卡西。卡西。卡西，我们在看着你呢。你知道吗？不过我喜欢你的那段话，你说，对不起，但我才不买账那种每年都有新升级、你非得花钱、还得换接口云云的鬼话。太多了。这太过分了。
laughed out loud because I feel like I have been at dinner parties or other events with you where we have given each other those looks when we run into a real life Todd Packer of sort. Yes, I loved that. I loved that. And then it also cuts over to Phyllis and she looks like she smelled a fart. I didn't get that one. I was still laughing about our double sneer. Aaron and Gabe arrived late. I guess Gabe fell in the shower. Gabe is being written more and more ridiculous as these episodes go. It's true. Well, when Aaron arrived, she is very excited to see a brand new computer on her desk. It's a humongous monitor. We got a fan question from Amy M and Winnipeg. Ever since I started working in an office
卡西是我们的百搭牌。我知道她是。她不随波逐流，但她确实也随波逐流。她不赶潮流。卡西，如果世上还有第三种既不是iPhone也不是安卓的手机，那会是你的手机吗？我是说，我确实怀念诺基亚的贪吃蛇。看我说的对吧？好吧，我告诉你吧，温尼伯的艾米。这不是苹果的付费植入广告。不过，菲尔·谢伊确实与加利福尼亚州库比蒂诺的苹果国际公司达成了一项协议，允许我们在节目中免费使用他们的产品。但当我们把这一集的粗剪版交给出品电视网时，我们收到了来自广告和销售部门措辞极其严厉的意见。不是标准与实践部门？没有。这一次，我们遭到来自广告
myself, it has bothered me that Pam bought an iMac for Aaron when the rest of the office has PCs. If they have any kind of shared system, this doesn't make any sense from an IT perspective. Is this a paid plug for Apple? That is such a good catch. It's like that one member of your family when everyone has an iPhone and they have an Android and you try to send pictures and videos and they're all little tiny compressed pieces of crap. Cassie. Cassie. Cassie, we're looking at you. You know what? I loved your speech, though, where you're like, I'm sorry, but I don't buy into the crap where every year there's a new upgrade and you got to pay for it and you got to change your toggle and blah, blah. It's too much. It's too much.
与销售部门的羞辱。来自广告销售部门的讽刺？听听看吧。他们说我们必须去掉艾伦显示器背后的苹果标志，否则他们就会帮我们打上马赛克。我是说，我们当时已经把这一集拍完了。问题是那个标志就像是烙在显示器背面一样。你懂我的意思吧？那他们是怎么处理的？好吧，我想与其让他们模糊处理，兰迪说我们进行了数字移除。而且这说得通，因为当时NBC向戴尔电脑等几家竞争对手出售了大量商业广告时间，他们不想让我们在节目中展示任何其他电脑标志。不过这太蠢了，因为那明摆着就是一台Mac。形状什么的都很明显。但如果你注意
Cassie's our wild card. I know she is. She doesn't go with the flow, but she does go with the flow. She doesn't go with the trends. Cassie, if there was a third phone that wasn't an iPhone or an Android, would that be your phone? I mean, I do miss Nokia playing Snake. See what I'm saying? Well, I'll tell you what, Amy, from Winnipeg. This was not a paid plug for Apple. However, Phil Shea did have a deal arranged with Apple International out of Cupertino, California, where we could use their products on air for free. But when we turned in our rough cut of this episode to the network, we got a very strongly worded note from advertising and sales. Not standards and practices? No. This time, we're getting the shame from advertising
到在第4分钟16秒，她显示器背面确实没有标志了，兰迪甚至还给我们发了处理前后的对比照片。我太喜欢他收集标志了。无标志。在艾伦给了帕姆一个大大的拥抱之后，这个场景还有后续。他们本该走到她的新电脑前，艾伦会说下面这番话。哦，天哪，我可以同时打开两个窗口了。然后艾伦会把手伸向电脑顶部说，它一点也不烫。接着她会低头看看自己的脚边说，我这里有更多的空间。我可以把腿盘起来了。然后她开始把腿晃来晃去。我记得当时拍的那场戏。你这么一说，我想起“盘腿”那部分了。帕姆高兴
and sales. Some ad sales snark? Let's hear it. They said that we had to lose the Apple logo on the back of Aaron's monitor or they were going to pixelate it for us. I mean, we'd already shot the episode. The thing is like burned into the back of the monitor. You know what I'm saying? So what'd they do? Well, I guess rather than have them blur it, Randy said we had it digitally removed. And that it made sense because at the time NBC was selling a lot of commercial time to several competitors like Dell computers, and they didn't want us to show any other computer logos on the air. That's so stupid though because it's clearly a Mac. Clearly the shape of it, everything. But if you notice
坏了。她走到吉姆身边说，我为别人做了一件好事。然后我们看到了吉姆的一点屁股特写。是的。他很懂这种感觉，因为他在凌晨4点花了整整一个小时帮女儿清理干净。德怀特要搬到附楼去了，一堆人打算过去抱怨。帕姆、吉姆、梅雷迪思、瑞恩、奥斯卡，他们想知道她为什么要雇佣托德。嗯。她说迈克尔给出了极高的评价，而且托德对她一直很好。在第6分钟02秒，安吉拉，霍莉的桌上是不是有一个法贝热彩蛋？为什么？我没看到那个。好吧，去看看。但还有，弗拉菲去哪儿了？弗拉菲不在那儿。我知道。她所有的旧东西都不在了
that four minutes, 16 seconds, there is no logo on the back of her monitor and Randy even sent us the before and after pictures. I love that he does logo. No logo. There was more to the scene after Aaron gives Pam a big hug. They would have gone over to her new computer and Aaron would have said the following. Oh my God, I can have two boxes open at one time. Then Aaron would run her hand across the top of the computer and say, it's not too hot. Then she would look down by her feet and say, and I've got so much more room down here. I can have crazy legs. And she starts to kick her legs around. I remember shooting that. I remember the crazy legs part now that you say it. Pam is so
。什么都没有。我知道。但这个彩蛋却突然出现了。回到办公大楼，安迪试图把大家聚在他的电脑周围观看雅茅斯帆船赛。但它加载遇到了困难，画面卡住了。他非常沮丧。我们收到了来自北卡罗来纳州的亚历山大B的粉丝提问，他说，我从小就玩小型帆船，我对安迪在电脑上观看帆船赛时编剧让他使用的专业术语印象深刻。更不用说，安迪对帆船赛如此狂热，这个笑料简直完美得爆笑。我和我丈夫几乎每天都会对彼此大喊，把帆兜起来，把帆兜起来。好吧，我很好奇雅茅斯在哪里。这到底是什么帆船赛？我谷歌了一下。哦，这就是
tickled. She goes over to Jim and she's like, I did something nice for somebody. And then we have a little bit of Jim's ass. Yeah. He knows the feeling because he cleaned up their daughter for an hour at 4am. Dwight is going to move to the annex and a bunch of people are going to head on over there to complain. Pam, Jim, Meredith, Ryan, Oscar, they want to know why she hired Todd. Mm-hmm. She says Michael gave him a glowing recommendation and Todd's been nothing but nice to her. At six minutes and two seconds, Angela, does Holly have a Faberge egg on her desk? And why? I did not see that. Well, check it out. But also what happened to Fluffy? Fluffy is not there. I know. None of her old stuff is
我找到的。如果你们这些听众知道更多，请告诉我。雅茅斯举行过一场帆船赛，它位于英国怀特岛上。哦，是的。看起来它通常在七月份举行。它由泰廷爵香槟赞助，并由皇家索伦特游艇俱乐部主办。我不得不查了一下“索伦特”。你知道索伦特是什么吗？不，那是什么？它是怀特岛与大不列颠之间的海峡。大约有20英里长，宽度各异，是客运、货运和军用舰艇的航道，我猜也是游艇的航道。哦，为了这场比赛？是的，我猜他们在那里举办了很多比赛，那里有一个网络摄像头，你可以查看索伦特海峡的情况，我看了，发现它非常平静。我昨晚去看了。
there. Nothing. I know. But this egg has suddenly appeared. Back in the bullpen, Andy is going to try to gather people around his computer to watch the Yarmuth regatta. But it was having trouble loading and it froze. He got very upset. We had a fan question from Alexandra B. in North Carolina who said, I used to raise small sailboats growing up and I was impressed with the terminology the writers had Andy use when he was watching the regatta on his computer. Not to mention, it was a hilariously perfect joke for Andy to be so hyped about a sailing regatta. My husband and I yell, luff him up, luff him up to each other almost daily. Well, I was curious where Yarmuth is. What is this regatta? I googled it. Oh, this
太符合你的作风了。我能想象到你做这种事。那里的景色确实非常如画。所以我猜这也许就是安迪正在观看的帆船赛。听起来是这样。当他无法观看时，他变得非常生气，并对帕姆大喊大叫。他说他也配得上一台新电脑，而帕姆则解释说，如果她给安迪买一台新电脑，她就得给销售部的每个人都买一台，而她根本没有这个预算。是的，这就是多米尼克骨牌效应。在成为办公室管理员之前，是谁在做这些决定？谁来处理这一切？我不知道。好吧，我们来到厨房。托德·帕克和霍莉、凯文以及德怀特在那里，托德·帕克正在某种程度上炫耀他
is what I found. If you guys out there know more about it, let me know. There is a regatta held in Yarmuth which is on the Isle of Wight in the UK. Oh, yeah. It looks like it's held usually in July. It's sponsored by Tattenger Champagne and hosted by the Royal Silent Yacht Club. I had to look up Sollent. Did you know what Sollent was? No, what is it? It is the strait between the Isle of Wight and Great Britain. It's about 20 miles long and varies in width and it's a shipping lane for passengers, freight and military vessels and I guess also for yachting. Oh, for this race? Yeah, I guess they hold lots of races there and there was a webcam where you can look at the Sollent and I did and I found it very calming. I went
性格中比较粗俗的一面。他管自己的女儿叫婊子。我知道。太俗气了，然后他还拿凯文的体重开玩笑。但德怀特居然为凯文辩护了，这有点暖心，我们收到了来自北卡罗来纳州的格温的粉丝提问，她说，从一个涉及德怀特、凯文和托德·帕克的场景中，我最没料到的是会有一个温馨的时刻。德怀特在这里太善良了，这真的展现了大家团结一致对抗帕克的决心。有句老话怎么说来着。没有什么比一个共同的敌人更能把人们凝聚在一起了。确实如此。格温想知道，安排这场对话是谁的主意。好吧，格温，我不知道是谁写的。我不知道这是阿梅莉的主意，还是编剧们想出的提纲的一部分，是剧本的某个桥段。但影音俱乐部的评论员迈尔斯·麦克纳特，还记得B减吗，迈尔斯·B减·麦克纳特，他确实很喜欢这个场景。他特别点名夸奖了这一场景，理由完全一样。
on last night. That's so you. I could see you doing that. It's just a really picturesque area. So I think maybe that's the regatta that Andy was watching. Sounds like it. He gets very angry when he can't watch it and he yells at Pam. He says he deserves a new computer as well and she explains that if she buys Andy a new computer, she's going to have to buy one for everyone in sales and she just doesn't have the budget for it. Yeah, it's a domino effect. Who made these decisions before she was office administrator? Who handled all this? I don't know. Well, here we go to the kitchen. Todd Packer is in there with Holly and Kevin and Dwight and Todd Packer is kind of showing off the saltier side of
帕姆从安迪的桌子旁走过，看到了艾伦的新电脑。艾伦把它给了安迪，帕姆很不高兴。没错。在第9分钟，你会注意到那个显示器的背面又没有标志了。好吧，帕姆要态度强硬起来了。她要告诉安迪他必须立刻把电脑换回来。是的。好吧，与此同时，回到艾伦的桌子旁，她问霍莉能不能把德怀特和蚂蚁农场带过来，霍莉同意了。但在路上，她被迈克尔拦了下来，他们将就托德·帕克展开一番长篇大论。
his personality. He calls his daughter a bitch. I know. So tacky and then he makes fun of Kevin's weight. But Dwight kind of comes to Kevin's defense and it's sort of sweet and we got a fan question about it from Gwen in North Carolina who said the last thing I expected from a scene involving Dwight, Kevin and Todd Packer was a heartfelt moment. Dwight is so kind here and it really shows how united the group is against Packer. There's that saying. Nothing brings people together better than a common enemy. It's so true. Gwen wanted to know whose idea was it to have this exchange. Well, Gwen, I don't know who wrote this. I don't know if it was Amelie's idea or if this was part of the outline that
霍莉试图向迈克尔解释，也许托德并不像迈克尔想象的那么搞笑。是的。他是个混蛋。她说他是个混蛋。我知道。我真的很喜欢霍莉列出的“什么才算搞笑”的清单。她试图说服迈克尔。她说，第一是比尔·科斯比。好吧。史蒂夫·马丁。好吧。查理咬了我的手指。迈克尔·斯科特。然后一路排到最后才是托德·帕克。好吧，我们收到了一些关于《查理咬了我的手指》的粉丝来信，来自佛罗里达州圣彼得堡的布雷F说，嗨，女士们，我今年21岁。当我听《办公室女郎》播客的那集《会议》时，你们两个解释了什么是黄页和白页。我之前没想到有些人可能不知道
the writers came up with, one of the script beats. But the AV club reviewer, Miles McNutt, remember B minus, Miles B minus McNutt, he did like this scene. He called out this scene for all the same reasons. Pam is going to walk by Andy's desk and see Aaron's new computer. Aaron gave it to him and Pam is not happy. That's right. At nine minutes, you'll notice no logo again on the back of that monitor. Well, Pam is going to put her foot down. She's going to tell Andy he has to switch the computers back immediately. Yeah. Well, meanwhile, back at Aaron's desk, she's going to ask Holly if she could bring Dwight and Aunt Farm and Holly agrees. But on her way, she gets stopped by Michael and they're going to have a whole
那是什么。但在这一集里，我确实觉得有些人可能不知道《查理咬了我的手指》是什么。你们觉得人们不知道《查理咬了我的手指》是什么吗？我是说，那难道不是YouTube上有史以来观看次数最多的视频之一吗？萨姆，你知道的，对吧？我知道。但我也觉得这是那种我们以为它发生得比实际时间更近的事情。因为我们老了。是的。让我说一下，这是一个YouTube视频，里面有两个小男孩，其中一个小男孩。我是说，他们很小。他们还是小不点。我记得。我好久没看过它了，但我清楚地记得。他们并排坐在一张躺椅上。其中一个可能还不到两岁。是的。另一个大概三岁半。
conversation about Todd Packer. And Holly's going to try to explain to Michael that maybe Todd is not as funny as Michael thinks he is. Yeah. He's a jerk. She says he's a jerk. I know. I really enjoyed Holly's list of what is funny. She's trying to get through to Michael. She says, first is Bill Cosby. Okay. Steve Martin. Okay. Charlie bit my finger. Michael Scott. And then all the way down here is Todd Packer. Well, we got some fan mail about Charlie bit my finger from Bre F in St. Pete, Florida, who said, Hi ladies, I'm 21 years old. And when I listened to the office ladies episode, the meeting, you two explained what the white and yellow pages were. It hadn't occurred to me that some people might not know what
是的。然后哥哥的手指被小弟弟咬了，他说，查理，查理咬了我的手指。是的。而查理觉得这太搞笑了。查理一直在咯咯笑。他乐不可支。而哥哥则说，查理，好疼啊。是的。而且还很疼。而查理乐不可支。所以他们是英国的两个小男孩。他们的爸爸把视频上传了，因为他们——以防你需要知道我们的口音是什么样的。没错。爸爸上传了这个视频，因为他只是想跟他们的教父分享一下，结果却意外走红了。你想猜猜日期吗，萨姆？你觉得这是哪一年的事？我觉得我想说这是几年前的事，但实际上，是15年前的事。
those were. But during this episode, I did think some people might not know what Charlie bit my finger is. Do you think people don't know what Charlie bit my finger is? I mean, isn't it like that one of the most viewed YouTube videos ever? Sam, you know it, right? I do. But I also think it's one of those things we think it's more recent than it is. Because we're old. Yeah. Let me say that this was a YouTube video where there's these two little boys and the one little boy. I mean, they're young. They're tiny. I remember it. I haven't seen it in so long, but I remember it clearly. They're sitting in like a recliner side by side. The one is like maybe not even two. Yeah. The other ones, maybe three and a half.
安吉拉，你觉得是哪一年？哦，珍娜。2007年。好的。2001年。萨姆，那是2007年。没错，确实是。这个视频迅速成为YouTube历史上观看次数最多的视频，拥有8.97亿次观看。哇。如果你敢相信的话，它后来已经被其他视频超越了。但我查了查这家人。查理现在15岁了。他的哥哥哈里，也就是视频里说话那个男孩，他18岁了。这家人还有另外两个儿子叫贾斯珀和鲁珀特。你知道吗，他们最后竟然在一次拍卖会上把这个视频当作NFT以76.6万美元的价格卖掉了？他们说他们打算用这笔钱支付孩子们的大学学费。我觉得这太棒了，因为我隐约记得它走红时，人们还不知道你可以通过
Yeah. And the older brother gets his finger bit by his little brother and he goes, Charlie, Charlie bit my finger. Yes. And Charlie thinks it's hilarious. Charlie keeps giggling. He's cracking up. And the older brother is like, Charlie, that hurt. Yeah. And it's still hurting. And Charlie is cracking up. So they're two little boys in the UK. Their dad uploaded the video because they just in case you needed to know what our accents were. Exactly. The dad had uploaded the video because he just wanted to share it with their godfather, but it ended up going viral. Do you want to guess the date, Sam? What year do you think this was? I feel like I want to say a couple of years ago, but in reality, 15 years ago.
YouTube视频获利。完全正确。所以他们本可以赚好多钱的。我要说，干得好，伙计们。去赚那笔钱吧，让它成为你们的福报，因为那个视频绝对给很多人带来了许多欢乐。15年甚至更久。是的。在这期间，迈克尔和霍莉一直在争论不休，艾伦则全神贯注地看着蚂蚁农场。霍莉把它夹在胳膊底下。她不断插话并说，你知道的，如果你不拿的话，我可以拿。我觉得它们饿了。关于这个蚂蚁农场，我发现了一件有趣的事。本集里出现的蚂蚁农场是一个米尔顿叔叔牌蚂蚁农场。菲尔·谢伊买的。大约花了我23美元。你可以在亚马逊上找到它们。
Ang, what do you think it was? Oh, Jenna. 2007. Okay. 2001. Sam, it was 2007. Yes, it was. This video quickly became the most viewed YouTube video of all time with 897 million views. Whoa. If you can believe it, it has since been surpassed by other videos. But I looked up this family. Charlie is now 15. His older brother, Harry, was the boy who was talking in the video. He's 18. The family has two more sons named Jasper and Rupert. And did you know that they ended up selling this video as an NFT for $760,000 at an auction? And they said that they plan to use the money to pay for their kids' colleges. I think that's great because I sort of remember that it went viral before people knew that you could monetize
但我读到了一篇关于在《纽约市报》发明了这个蚂蚁农场的米尔顿·莱文的精彩文章。米尔顿叔叔？是的。米尔顿·莱文。文章是这么写的。1956年，米尔顿·莱文灵光一现。他在南加州他姐姐的泳池边度过独立日野餐时，发现了一堆蚂蚁。回想起他小时候在宾夕法尼亚州他叔叔的农场里用罐子收集蚂蚁的情景，他对他的连襟兼商业伙伴说，我们应该做一个蚂蚁饲养箱。由此产生的产品——米尔顿叔叔的蚂蚁农场，从那以后就成了儿童卧室里的常青树。已经售出了两000多万个。这让我着迷的地方在于，因为作为父母，我曾关注过蚂蚁农场
a YouTube video. That's absolutely right. So they would have made so much money. And I say go for it, you guys. Get that coin and let it be a blessing to you because that video absolutely brought so many people a lot of joy. For 15 years and counting. Yeah. This whole time, Michael and Holly are going back and forth, Erin is preoccupied with the ant farm. Holly has tucked it under her arm. She keeps inserting and saying things like, you know, if you're not going to take it, I can take it. I think they're getting hungry. Here's something fun I found out about the ant farm. The ant farm featured in this episode is an Uncle Milton ant farm. Phil Shea bought it. It cost about $23. You can find them on Amazon.
一段YouTube视频。完全正确。所以他们一定赚了好多钱。我想说，加油，伙计们。去赚那笔钱，让它成为你们的福祉，因为那段视频确实给很多人带来了许多欢乐。已经15年了，而且还在继续。是的。这段时间里，迈克尔和霍莉一直在来回拉扯，艾琳则全神贯注于蚂蚁农场。霍莉把它夹在胳膊底下。她不停地插话并说诸如“你知道的，如果你不拿走，我可以拿走。我想它们饿了”之类的话。关于蚂蚁农场，我发现了一件有趣的事。本集中出现的蚂蚁农场是“米尔顿叔叔”品牌的蚂蚁农场。菲尔·谢伊买的。大约花了23美元。你可以在亚马逊上找到它们。
But I read a great article about Milton Levine who invented this ant farm in the New York Times. Uncle Milton? Yes. Milton Levine. Here's what the article said. In 1956, Milton Levine had a Eureka moment. He spotted a mound of ants during a Fourth of July picnic at his sister's poolside in Southern California. Recalling as a boy how he had collected ants and jars at his uncle's farm in Pennsylvania, he told his brother-in-law and business partner, we should make an ant uranium. The resulting product, Uncle Milton's ant farm, has been a staple in children's bedrooms ever since. More than 20 million have been sold. The thing that fascinates me about this because as a parent, I have looked into the ant farm is
但我《纽约时报》上读到了一篇关于发明了这个蚂蚁农场的米尔顿·莱文的精彩文章。米尔顿叔叔？是的。米尔顿·莱文。文章是这样说的：1956年，米尔顿·莱文有了一个灵光一现的时刻。他在南加州他姐姐家泳池边的一次独立日野餐中，发现了一个蚁丘。回想起小时候在宾夕法尼亚州他叔叔的农场里用罐子收集蚂蚁的情景，他告诉他的小舅子兼商业伙伴，我们应该做一个蚂蚁饲养箱。由此产生的产物——“米尔顿叔叔的蚂蚁农场”，从那以后就成了儿童卧室里的常青树。已经售出了两千多万个。让我对这个感到着迷的是，因为作为父母，我曾仔细了解过蚂蚁农场，那就是
that they send you a little tube of ants. A little vial of them. Yeah. Live ants that you add to the farm. But how many times, Angela, do you think that the transfer from the tube to the house has gone awry? I know. I'm sure I'm going to say this wrong. I'm positive I am. But the type of ants that are in the ant farm are Pogonomerex californicus. Collected ants from California. Oh, just like the ones he saw in the little mound by the pool. Mr. Levine, he was quoted as saying this about the ants. Okay. I found out their most amazing feat yet, he said. They put three kids through college. Mr. Levine passed away. He was 97 years old and his company, the Uncle Milton Industries, was sold to Transom Capital
他们会给你寄一小管蚂蚁。一小瓶。对。你可以放进蚁场里的活蚂蚁。但是安琪拉，你觉得从试管转移到屋子里出错的情况有多少次？我懂。我肯定会说错。我百分之百会。但蚁场里的那种蚂蚁是 Pogonomerex californicus。从加利福尼亚收集的蚂蚁。哦，就像他在泳池边的小土堆里看到的那样。勒温先生，人们引述他关于这些蚂蚁的话是这样的。好吧。我发现了它们迄今为止最了不起的壮举，他说。它们供三个孩子上了大学。勒温先生去世了。他享年 97 岁，他的公司“米尔顿叔叔工业”被 Transom Capital
Group for more than $20 million. Wow. Wow. That really shows you how a little idea can turn into something that's in every kid's bedroom. Yes, Jenna. Mr. Levine once said of his company's success, most novelties, if they last one season, it's a lot. If they last two seasons, it's a phenomenon. But to last 35 years is unheard of. It's true. I know. Well, I loved that. I think we should take a break. Oh, yes, because when we come back, I want to share with you guys that the scene would have continued and we learned a little bit about Holly's friend Lois. I can't wait. We're back. So in the episode that aired, Erin grabs the ant farm, right? Yes. She can't take it. She can't take it
集团以超过 2000 万美元的价格收购。哇。哇。这真的向你展示了一个小创意是如何变成每个小孩子的卧室里都有的东西的。是的，珍娜。勒温先生曾这样评价他公司的成功，大多数新奇玩意儿，如果能维持一个季度，那就很多了。如果它们能维持两个季度，那就是个奇迹。但能维持 35 年是闻所未闻的。确实。我懂。嗯，我很喜欢这个。我想我们该休息一下。哦，是的，因为当我们回来时，我想和大家分享，这个场景本该继续，我们会对霍莉的朋友洛伊丝有更多的了解。我等不及了。我们回来了。所以在播出的那一集里，艾琳抓起了蚁场，对吧？是的。她受不了了。她再也
anymore. The scene would have continued with Michael and Holly in the annex at Holly's desk. Part of it is in deleted scenes. And we learn about Holly's friend Lois and pretty much how she drives Michael crazy. Oh my gosh, Angela, we got a fan question about this. Okay. Okay. It's from Narissa C. from Cedar City, Utah, who said, this is probably a question for Angela since she is the queen of the deleted scenes. Thank you, Narissa. I first saw the deleted scene about Holly's friend Lois in 2015. I had become disabled about two years before that and started using a service dog who is still my partner today. In the scene, Steve Carell is absolute perfection. Somehow he is able to capture both the perspective
受不了了。这个场景本该由迈克尔和霍莉在霍莉桌子旁的附属办公室继续。其中一部分在删减片段中。我们了解到了霍莉的朋友洛伊丝，以及她是怎么把迈克尔逼疯的。哦天哪，安琪拉，我们收到了一个关于这的粉丝提问。好吧。好的。来自犹他州雪松城的娜丽莎·C，她说，这可能是一个给安琪拉的问题，因为她是删减片段女王。谢谢你，娜丽莎。我是在 2015 年第一次看到关于霍莉的朋友洛伊丝的删减片段。在那之前大约两年，我残疾了，并开始使用一只直到今天依然是我的伙伴的服务犬。在那个场景中，史蒂夫·卡瑞尔简直完美。不知何故，他能够同时捕捉到
of himself wanting to pet a cute dog and Lois, who is tiredly trying to explain that just because her guide dog is hanging out doesn't mean he isn't still on duty. I have been the person holding the leash in this exact situation so many times, and I thought the writing and execution was delightful on all sides. Who wrote this scene? Well, Narissa, I am not exactly sure who wrote the scene. If it was Amelie or if the group wrote it, I kind of feel like it might have been a group written scene because there are so many candy bag alts for Lois, and they are fantastic. Let's start first by playing the scene you're talking about in deleted scenes. It is important to me that you like him. Well, honey, look,
自己想要抚摸一只可爱狗狗的心情，以及洛伊丝那种疲惫地试图解释的视角，即仅仅因为她的导盲犬在闲逛并不意味着它不在工作状态。在完全相同的情况下，我曾无数次成为那个握着牵引绳的人，我认为各方面的剧本编写和呈现都非常令人愉悦。这个场景是谁写的？嗯，娜丽莎，我不太确定这个场景是谁写的。是阿米莉写的，还是大家集体创作的？我总觉得这可能是集体创作的场景，因为针对洛伊丝有太多糖果袋式的替代台词，而且它们棒极了。让我们首先播放一下你谈到的那个删减片段。我希望你喜欢他，这对我来说很重要。好吧，亲爱的，听着，
I don't have to like all your friends. You don't like Lois? Lois is a, no, no, I don't. Lois is disgusting. She thinks she's better than everybody else. Case in point. You're not allowed to pet my seeing eye dog. Well, he wants me to. Well, he's working, and he has a job to do. Well, you're just sitting down. Well, I'm asking you nicely. Well, I'm asking you nicely. Well, I wish you wouldn't. Well, I want to pet your dog. Oh my gosh. Oh my gosh. I know. He's so annoyed that Lois won't let him pet her dog, and she has good reason. Yes. It's not just a dog. It's working. I know. Well, Narissa, this scene had so many candy bag alts. I went to the shooting draft, and I just have to read them.
我没必要喜欢你所有的朋友。你不喜欢洛伊丝？洛伊丝是个，不，不，我不喜欢。洛伊丝太讨厌了。她觉得自己比其他所有人都高人一等。典型例子。你不准摸我的导盲犬。嗯，他想让我摸。嗯，他在工作，他有工作要做。嗯，你只是在坐着。嗯，我在好言相劝。嗯，我也在好言相劝。嗯，我希望你别这样。嗯，我想摸你的狗。哦天哪。哦天哪。我知道。他太恼火了，因为洛伊丝不让他摸她的狗，而她有充分的理由。是的。这不只是一只狗。它在工作。我知道。嗯，娜丽莎，这个场景有太多的糖果袋替代台词了。我查了拍摄剧本，我必须把它们读出来。
Okay. Please. They all start with Michael's talking head where he says Lois is disgusting. She thinks she's better than everyone else. Then in the script, it said Michael continues in an annoying voice like he's talking as Lois. So here are all the alts. I work for the Environmental Defense Fund. I take my backpack everywhere. I use a thermos. Oh, listen, a cardinal. Do you have nonfat dressing? What beautiful architecture. I'm thinking of taking a pottery class. Do you eat to live or live to eat? Read anything good lately? I love that shirt. Michael, you look great. What did you two do last night? I can tell when you're tired. I'm not quiet. I'm pensive. Do you think I should call Marcus? Introduce
好的。请吧。它们都以迈克尔的单人访谈开头，他说洛伊丝太讨厌了。她觉得自己比所有人都要高人一等。然后在剧本里写着，迈克尔用一种烦人的声音继续说，就像他在模仿洛伊丝说话一样。所以这些就是所有的替代台词。我为环境国防基金会工作。我随身带着双肩包。我用保温杯。哦，听，是一只红衣凤头鸟。你们有脱脂酱汁吗？多么美丽的建筑。我在考虑去上陶艺课。你是为了吃而活还是为了活着而吃？最近读了什么好书吗？我喜欢那件衬衫。迈克尔，你看起来真棒。你们俩昨晚做什么了？我看得出你什么时候累了。我不是沉默寡言。我是沉思。你觉得我该给马库斯打电话吗？把
me to Dwight. How's your mom doing? I had to stop reading the newspaper. Oh my gosh. I could listen to those all day. I know. I want a whole play written based on that dialogue right there, on those lines. I want to play this character. Lois. Yeah. I know. Who says all these things. And some of them are perfectly nice. I know. They just drive Michael crazy. That was what I loved about it. I love that shirt. Exactly. I want to deliver the line like that, though. Well, the scene continues after this Lois moment, and Holly tells Michael the truth. What everyone thinks of Todd Packer. Let's hear it. Look, it's not just me. Everybody in the office wants him gone. Okay. You know what? People are a little indifferent toward
我介绍给德怀特。你妈妈最近怎么样？我不得不停止读报纸。哦天哪。我可以听这些听上一整天。我知道。我想根据那段对话，根据那些台词写一整出戏剧。我想扮演这个角色。洛伊丝。对。我知道。说所有这些话的人。其中有些台词其实挺友好的。我知道。它们只是把迈克尔逼疯了。这就是我喜欢它的地方。我喜欢那件衬衫。没错。不过，我想用那种语气把台词说出来。嗯，这个场景在洛伊丝的这个时刻之后继续，霍莉告诉了迈克尔真相。大家对托德·帕克的看法。让我们听听。听着，不只是我。办公室里的所有人都想让他走。好吧。你知道吗？大家对他的态度有点无所谓。
him. That's fine. They hate Packer. No. They're indifferent to Gabe. Who exactly has a beef with him? Without naming names. Everyone. Everyone. That conversation motivates Michael to have a one-on-one conversation with Packer. Oh. First, Todd is going to pepper Jim and Pam about their married sex life, and Dwight is going to try to give Todd some hot chocolate with a laxative in it. This scene made me laugh so hard because Dwight is so bad. He's so bad at espionage. He's like, no, you should drink it. Here, drink it. Oh, don't you want to drink it? But he also gives like 90 million reasons why he's prepared it. I know. So Jim has to pull Dwight into the kitchen. He has to try to explain that you can't give Todd
那倒也行。他们讨厌帕克。不。他们对加布无所谓。到底谁跟他有意见？别点名。所有人。所有人。那段对话促使迈克尔与帕克进行了一对一的谈话。哦。首先，托德要追问吉姆和帕姆的已婚性生活，而德怀特则试图给托德一些加了泻药的热巧克力。这个场景把我逗得哈哈大笑，因为德怀特太逊了。他在谍报工作上太逊了。他说，不，你应该喝。来，喝吧。哦，你难道不想喝吗？但他同时也给出了大约九千万个他准备好这个的理由。我知道。所以吉姆不得不把德怀特拉进厨房。他不得不试图解释，你不能给托德
a cup of hot chocolate with a laxative in it. Well, public service announcement, don't laxative someone. Yeah, don't do that. That's terrible. I think Jim convinces Dwight of this because instead, Jim tells Dwight he'll come up with a bunch of other ideas. Well, there's my favorite, favorite couplet of dialogue makes me laugh every time when Jim's like, this isn't my best, but I could call Froggy101, say we're the tour manager for Justin Bieber, and we're giving out free tickets, and we give a number to call for the tickets and his packers. And Dwight says, who is Justice Beaver? I know. And Jim says, it's a crime fighting beaver. Never, never mind. I googled Justice Beaver and there's so much fan art
一杯加了泻药的热巧克力。好吧，公共服务公告，不要给别人下泻药。对，别那么做。那太糟糕了。我想吉姆说服了德怀特，因为相反，吉姆告诉德怀特他会想出一堆其他的主意。嗯，这里有我最最喜欢的对白，每次都能把我逗笑，当吉姆说，这不是我最好的主意，但我可以打电话给 Froggy101，说我们是贾斯汀·比伯的巡演经理，我们要送出免费门票，我们给出一个打电话领取门票的号码，而那就是帕克的电话。而德怀特说，谁是正义海狸？我知道。而吉姆说，是一只打击犯罪的海狸。算了，算了。我谷歌了一下正义海狸，有那么多的同人图
of like a very, a crime fighting beaver fired up beaver. You know, when I watched this scene, it did make me wonder if Billie Eilish thought that Justice Beaver was a real crime fighting beaver. No. It did. It did. Because she said she believed stuff. What do you think? You'll have to text her and ask her. I'm going to ask her. Well, listen, in this scene at 12 minutes and 34 seconds, we had a fan question from Hannah C in Indiana. Hannah said, when Dwight and Jim are talking in the kitchen about how to annoy Todd Packer, I noticed a couple of boxes of tasty cakes on top of the fridge behind Dwight. I lived in Pennsylvania for a few years as a kid. And these were my favorite snacks. They are an east coast thing
关于一只非常，一只打击犯罪的海狸，一只斗志昂扬的海狸。你知道，当我看到这个场景时，它确实让我怀疑比利·艾利什是否认为正义海狸是一只真正的打击犯罪的海狸。没有。确实如此。确实。因为她说她相信那些东西。你觉得呢？你得发信息问问她。我要去问她。嗯，听着，在这个场景的 12 分钟 34 秒处，我们收到了印第安纳州汉娜·C 的粉丝提问。汉娜说，当德怀特和吉姆在厨房谈论如何惹恼托德·帕克时，我注意到德怀特身后的冰箱顶上有几盒泰滋蛋糕（Tasty Cakes）。我小时候在宾夕法尼亚州住过几年。这些是我最喜欢的零食。它们是东海岸的东西，
and are near impossible to find outside of the region. So I just wanted to say that I love the attention to detail. Well, guess what, guys? You brought some. I brought some tasty cakes. You know what? As you were saying it, I don't know if it's because I'm hungry. I was thinking, I wish I had a tasty cake right now. There are two boxes of tasty cakes on top of the fridge in this scene. And this is one of the ones that was featured. This is the peanut butter candy cake. Oh my God, give it to me. It is a cake with chocolate flavored coating and a peanut butter filling. Imagine like a sort of round. It looks like a cookie. It looks like a kind of a chocolate cookie with cake filling. Well, it's got cake,
在这个地区之外几乎不可能找到。所以我只是想说，我喜欢这种对细节的关注。嗯，你猜怎么着，伙计们？你带了一些。我带了一些泰滋蛋糕。你知道吗？正如你所说的那样，我不知道是不是因为我饿了。我在想，我真希望现在能有一个泰滋蛋糕。在这个场景中，冰箱顶上有两盒泰滋蛋糕。而这就是其中出现的那款。这是花生酱糖果蛋糕。哦天哪，给我。这是一个外面裹着巧克力风味涂层、里面有花生酱夹心的蛋糕。想象一下类似于某种圆形的东西。它看起来像一块曲奇。它看起来有点像带有蛋糕夹心的巧克力曲奇。嗯，它有蛋糕，
a layer of caramel, and it's sort of covered in chocolate. Sam, you got to have one for you too. Oh, that is tasty. That's a tasty cake. Is it a tasty cake? Oh, that's delightful. I'm going to try one. These do have gluten in them, but I think I can eat one bite. You know what I like? I love the salty and the sweet. That's making me happy. So I looked it up. Tasty Cake is a Philadelphia company. It has been around for over a hundred years. Oh, tasty cakes. In 1914, Philip Bauer and Herbert Morris, who was an egg salesman, raised $50,000 from their family members and they founded Tasty Baking Company. Did you say egg salesman? He was an egg salesman. Okay. Philip's father had been in the bakery business,
一层焦糖，而且基本上裹满了巧克力。萨姆，你也得来一个。哦，真好吃。真是个好吃的蛋糕。是个好吃的蛋糕吗？哦，太美味了。我要尝一个。这里面确实有麸质，但我想我可以吃一口。你知道我喜欢什么吗？我喜欢咸甜交织的味道。这让我很开心。所以我查了一下。泰滋蛋糕是一家费城公司。它已经存在了一百多年了。哦，泰滋蛋糕。1914 年，菲利普·鲍尔和身为鸡蛋销售员的赫伯特·莫里斯从他们的家人那里筹集了 5 万美元，创立了泰滋烘焙公司。你刚才说鸡蛋销售员？他是个鸡蛋销售员。好吧。菲利普的父亲一直在烘焙行业，
so he had a little bakery knowledge, but he teamed up with an egg salesman. Who knew that was a thing back in 1914? I'm pretty sure. Probably like a milkman. I was going to say, I'm sure our grandparents would be like, sure, you had the egg guy, you had your milk guy. Right? Their idea was that they wanted to produce individually wrapped snack cakes and deliver them fresh daily. Herbert's wife, Willavine, tried one and said, quote, what a tasty cake. Just like you, Angela. And that is how they got their name. They were originally delivered by a horse. Yeah. And I guess this horse and buggy was very popular on the streets of Philadelphia. In the early 1930s, they added individually wrapped pies. These were a big
所以他有一点烘焙知识，但他与一个鸡蛋销售员合作了。谁知道 1914 年还有这种职业？我很确定。可能就像送奶工一样。我正要说，我敢肯定我们的爷爷奶奶会说，当然，你有送鸡蛋的，你有送牛奶的。对吧？他们的想法是生产独立包装的小吃蛋糕，并每天新鲜配送。赫伯特的妻子威拉维因尝了一个，然后说，引述一下，“多好吃的蛋糕啊。”就像你一样，安琪拉。这就是他们名字的由来。它们最初是由马匹配送的。对。我猜这种马车在费城的街道上非常受欢迎。在 20 世纪 30 年代初，他们增加了独立包装的派。这些在午餐盒里非常受欢迎，
hit in the lunch boxes. And in the 1980s, the company expanded beyond Philadelphia from New England to Florida and as far west as Ohio, but that's it. I had to order these through the mail. They're delicious. Thank you for doing that. I needed it. I needed that tasty cake pickup. The texture is very pleasing. Very pleasing. It feels good to bite into. I agree with you. Also, the way you said that line makes it seem like just a horse brought them. The tasty cake horse is here. And it made me very happy. Interestingly enough, tasty cakes was my nickname in high school. No, it was not. I'm cracking myself up today. Okay. Andy is going to ask Pam to speak to him privately, please. He has signed
而在 20 世纪 80 年代，公司将业务扩展到了费城以外，从新英格兰到佛罗里达，最远向西到俄亥俄州，但也就到此为止了。我不得不通过邮购买到这些。它们太美味了。谢谢你这么做。我需要这个。我需要那个泰滋蛋糕来提提神。口感非常令人满意。非常令人满意。咬下去的感觉很好。我同意你的看法。而且，你念那句台词的方式让人觉得就像只是一匹马把它们送来的一样。泰滋蛋糕之马来了。这让我非常开心。有趣的是，泰滋蛋糕是我高中的绰号。才不是呢。我今天把自己逗得哈哈大笑。好吧。安迪要请帕姆跟他单独谈谈，拜托。他在自己制作的报名板上，
them up for three five minute mods in the conference room on the sign up board that he created. It's so odd. Five minutes. Five mods. I have to think this is from Andy's RA days. Oh, yes. Right? Yes. You have two mods with the RA. I googled mods. Is this a college term? I looked. All I could find is that at Boston College, there's some housing called the mods, but I couldn't find it as an increment of time. I feel like, though, this was something Andy used when he was the RA. Well, Andy really lays into Pam in the conference room for humiliating him in front of everybody. And she sort of quickly says, oh, wow, well, I really didn't think of it that way. But she holds firm and kind of says,
为他们安排了会议室里的三个五分钟小模块。太奇怪了。五分钟。五个小模块。我不得不认为这是安迪当宿舍管理员（RA）时留下的习惯。哦，是的。对吧？是的。你跟宿舍管理员有两个模块。我谷歌了一下模块。这是一个大学术语吗？我查了。我能找到的唯一信息是，在波士顿学院有一些被称为模块的宿舍，但我找不到它作为时间增量。不过，我觉得这是安迪当宿舍管理员时使用的方法。嗯，安迪在会议室里把帕姆狠狠数落了一顿，因为她在所有人面前羞辱了他。而她有点迅速地说，哦，哇，好吧，我真的没那么想。但她态度坚决，有点像是说，
I cannot replace your computer unless it breaks all the way. And then they get like a little sinister look in their eyes. I think they know what they have to do. Andy says, pretty sneaky sis. I thought Ed improvised that. I went to the script. And it's exactly as it's written. No way. Yeah. But what was interesting is a little tidbit in the shooting draft when Ryan and his band enter. In the shooting draft, it reads like this. There's a loud wrap at the door. It's Ryan and Hank. And there are three other Hank aged musicians with jazz instruments. Ryan says, hey, cats, we have a jam session in mods six, nine and 12. And then it would have cut to a Ryan talking head where Ryan would have said, apparently, you're not allowed to sign up for
除非你的电脑彻底坏了，否则我不能给你换一台。然后他们的眼神中流露出一种有点阴险的神色。我想他们知道他们必须做什么了。安迪说，挺狡猾的嘛，妹子。我以为那是埃德即兴发挥的。我查了剧本。完全就是剧本里写的。不会吧。是的。但有趣的是，拍摄剧本里有一个小花絮，那是瑞安和他的乐队登场的时候。在拍摄剧本中，它是这样写的。门被敲得很响。是瑞安和汉克。还有其他三个汉克年纪的、拿着爵士乐器的音乐家。瑞安说，嘿，伙计们，我们在 6、7、9 和 12 号模块有个即兴演奏会。然后镜头本该切到一个瑞安的单人访谈，瑞安会说，显然，你不被允许报名参加连续的模块。
consecutive mods. Oh my gosh, Angela, we got fan mail about that. So many people asked, why would you create a system where you can't have a second of time? Yeah. And I thought, well, I'll never get the answer to that. So I didn't include it. Oh my gosh. Well, everybody who wrote in, there's your answer. So you know, the musicians that enter with Ryan in that scene? Yeah. Randy said that normally, if you have a musician in an episode, you have to hire an American Federation of musicians player. Oh, it's sort of like a union for musicians. Right. Right. But he said that because we never hear the musicians play any instruments, he was able to just hire standard background performers provided we did not ask them to play
哦天哪，安琪拉，我们收到了关于这个的粉丝来信。很多人问，你为什么要创建一个连一秒钟都不能连续的时间系统？对。而我想，好吧，我永远不会得到这个答案。所以我没有把它放进去。哦天哪。好吧，所有写信来的人，这就是你们的答案。所以你知道，那个场景中跟瑞安一起进来的音乐家吗？是的。兰迪说，通常情况下，如果一集里有音乐家，你必须雇佣美国音乐家联合会的演奏者。哦，这有点像音乐家的工会。对。对。但他说，因为我们从未听到音乐家演奏任何乐器，他只需要雇佣标准的背景演员，只要我们不要求他们演奏甚至假装演奏乐器就行。但他们被允许把乐器带进来。我觉得这挺有趣的。是的。所有的规矩。我知道。有这么多的规矩。显然安迪对他的模块有很多规矩。他确实如此。
or even pretend to play the instruments. But they were allowed to carry them in. I thought that was kind of interesting. Yeah. All the little rules. I know. So many rules. And apparently Andy has a lot of rules for his mods. He sure does. Jim is going to present Dwight with a list of 400 ideas. Ah, eat a frog, eat a dog, eat a brog. It reminded me of that children's book, Oi Frog. Do you know that book? We got it in the UK when we lived in London when I did that TV show there. No, I don't know it. Oh my gosh. It's the cutest book. It's called Oi Frog. And it's about a cat. And the cat is explaining to a frog that the only thing he can sit on is
吉姆要向德怀特展示一个包含 400 个主意的清单。啊，吃只青蛙，吃只狗，吃只布罗蛙。这让我想起了那本儿童读物《喂，青蛙》（Oi Frog）。你知道那本书吗？我们在伦敦生活时在英国买的，当时我在那儿拍那个电视节目。不，我不知道。哦天哪。这是最可爱的书。它叫《喂，青蛙》。讲的是一只猫。猫向青蛙解释说，他唯一能坐的地方是一截圆木，因为他是一只青蛙。他接着说，猫解释道，猫可以坐在垫子上，青蛙坐在圆木上。这是一本带押韵的小书。但关于它真正可爱的地方，安琪拉，是有些韵脚只有当你用英国口音朗读时才管用。你喜欢它吗？所以就像，纽芬兰犬坐在长笛上，海雀坐在松鼠蛋糕上，黄鼠狼坐在画架上。但随后它会说，比如，大猩猩坐在柱子上。带 R 音的柱子？对，你知道的，就像建筑物的柱子。对，大猩猩坐在柱子上。所以你必须说大猩猩坐在柱子上。因为这样才能押韵。对，大猩猩坐在柱子上。是的。这本书听起来太可爱了。我想看看。你知道吗？我发个链接给你。我们可以把它发在快拍里。我喜欢好的 Instagram 快拍。我知道你喜欢，安琪拉。
a log because he's a frog. And he goes on, the cat explains, cats can sit on mats, frogs sit on logs. And it's a little rhyming book. But what's really cute about it, Angela, is that some of the rhymes only work if you read it in a British accent. Did you love it? So it's like, newts sit on flutes, puffins sit on muffins, weasels sit on easels. But then it'll say like, gorillas sit on pillars. Pillars with an R? Yeah, you know, like a pillar for a building. Yeah, gorillas sit on pillars. So you have to say gorillas sit on pillars. Because then it rhymes. Right, gorillas sit on pillars. Yes. This book sounds adorable. I want to see it. You know what? I'll send you a link. We can post about it in the stories. I love a good Insta story. I know you do, Angela.
好吧，听起来就像吉姆拿了一个短语，然后让电脑浏览并通过修改一个字母来改变它。没错。然后按下回车、回车、回车。生成了 400 个主意。我们在咖啡角有一个场景。这个场景本来是由刚才迈克尔和霍莉的那个场景引出的，在那个场景中迈克尔要跟托德谈谈。在拍摄剧本中，它是这样开头的，帕克和迈克尔在吧台喝酒。汉克拿着一个 76 人队的标志杯。帕克对汉克说。嘿，76 人队球迷。托德在小费罐里放了一块钱。汉克点点头，笑了。迈克尔很高兴。迈克尔说，嘿，帕克，你需要把那种魅力带一些到楼上的办公区去。他向他解释说，你在路上待了很久，你一直是一只室外猫。而
Well, it just sounded like Jim took one phrase and then let the computer just go through and alter it by one letter. Exactly. And hit return, return, return. For 400 ideas. We have a scene down at caffeine corner. This is the scene that would have been set up by that Michael Holly scene earlier where Michael's going to talk to Todd. And the shooting draft, it started with this, Packer and Michael are drinking at the bar. Hank has a 76ers tip cup. Packer to Hank. Hey, 76ers fan. Todd puts a buck in the tip jar. Hank nods and smiles. Michael is delighted. Michael's like, Hey, Packer, you need to take some of that charm upstairs to the bullpen. And he explains to him, you've been on the road a long time, and you've been an outdoor cat. And
现在你必须成为一只室内猫，所以你不能随地在墙上撒尿。托德说，你知道吗？你说得对。我得注意我的行为。他说，别对我失去信心。这是一个非常真诚的时刻，对吧？迈克尔说，我不会的。嗯，在拍摄剧本中，这个场景本该以另一个节拍结束。迈克尔本该说，这里永远有你的位置。然后汉克会在迈克尔和帕克面前摆上两块意大利脆饼。而帕克会说，呃，把这根鸡巴饼干从我眼前拿开。对不起，迈尔斯。这更符合托德·帕克的风格。好吧，在这段对话之后，
now you have to be an indoor cat so you can't be peeing all over the walls. And Todd's like, you know what? You're right. I got to watch my behavior. And he says, don't give up on me. And it's this really honest moment, right? And Michael's like, I won't. Well, in the shooting draft, the scene would have ended with one more beat. Michael would have said, you'll always have a place here. And then Hank would place two biscotti treats in front of Michael and Packer. And Packer would say, ew, get this dick cookie out of my face. Sorry, Miles. That's more Todd Packer for you. Well, after this conversation,
迈克尔要带托德去办公区公开向凯文道歉。是的，进展并不顺利。没人买账。他们都觉得，这是个假道歉。尽管凯文说，不，不，不，我不需要这个。我很好。是的。然后帕克说，好吧，你想要一个真诚的道歉？来吧。凯文，我太抱歉了。你很瘦而且是个天才。是的。然后迈克尔说，好吧，这结果不是我想要的。于是迈克尔开始试图为为什么托德·帕克的生活中也有其他事情进行辩解，就像其他人一样，对吧？是的。试图为托德博取一些同情。是的。有一个时刻我差点没挺过去。我几乎没法把台词说出口
Michael is going to bring Todd to the bullpen to publicly apologize to Kevin. Yeah, it doesn't go well. No one buys this. They're all like, this is a fake apology. Even though Kevin's like, no, no, no, I don't need this. I'm fine. Yeah. And then Packer's like, OK, you want a real apology? Here it goes. Kevin, I am so sorry. You are skinny and a genius. Yeah. And Michael's like, OK, that didn't turn out how I wanted it to. So Michael starts to try to justify why Todd Packer also has other things going on in his life, just like everyone else, right? Yeah. Trying to create some sympathy for Todd. Yeah. There is a moment I barely got through. I could barely say my line
而不笑场。我只是觉得我们应该听听这个。帕克是离婚的幸存者，斯坦利。帕克不和他的孩子说话，梅雷迪思。帕克从不符合他父母的期望，安迪。安琪拉喜欢小猫。帕克，我本想说狗的。好吧，你知道吗？这结束了。道歉已经道了，我们不提了。帕克会在这里待到他死的那一天，就像我们其余的人一样。当我观看这一段时，我非常喜欢它，因为我不记得这句台词了。我本想说狗的。所以事情是这样的。我拍摄时频频笑场的原因之一是因为在拍摄剧本中，它是这样写的。就在迈克尔说的那句台词之后，你知道，安迪，托德从来没有达到他父母的期望，
without laughing. I just thought we should hear it. Packer is a survivor of divorce, Stanley. Packer doesn't speak with his child, Meredith. Packer never lived up to his parents' expectations, Andy. Angela loves pussycats. Packer, I was going to say dogs. OK, you know what? This is over. Apology has been issued and we're through with it. Packer's going to be here until the day he dies, just like the rest of us. I loved that so much when I watched it because I didn't remember the line. I was going to say dogs. So here's the thing. One of the reasons why I kept breaking when we shot this is because in the shooting draft, it was written like this. Right after the line where Michael says, and you know, Andy, Todd never lived up to his parents' expectations,
有一个停顿，迈克尔扫视了房间。还有谁？我还能把谁和托德·帕克联系起来？上面写着迈克尔发现了安琪拉。然后你会听到他试图建立某种联系。迈克尔说，帕克和安琪拉。帕克和安琪拉。帕克，安琪拉。安琪拉喜欢小猫，而帕克喜欢。然后安琪拉说，别。不。但这就是那种铺垫。你知道史蒂夫是怎么做到这一点的吗？是的。那一刻他在扫视房间，然后就像是，帕克，安琪拉。帕克，安琪拉。我明白了。每一次都把我逗笑。而整个那一刻并没有剪进正片，只有那句台词。但每一次史蒂夫饰演的迈克尔锁定我的目光时，我都笑崩了。我想吉姆和德怀特已经敲定了他们的恶作剧，以及他们将如何把托德
there was a beat where Michael scanned the room. Who else? Who else can I connect Todd Packer to? And it said Michael spots Angela. And then you kind of hear him trying to make a connection. Michael says, Packer and Angela. Packer and Angela. Packer, Angela. Angela loves pussycats and Packer loves. And then Angela goes, don't. No. But it was that buildup. You know how Steve could do that? Yes. That moment where he's scanning the room and then it's like, Packer, Angela. Packer, Angela. I got it. Every time that got me. And that whole moment didn't make it in, just the line. But every single time Steve is Michael locked eyes with me, I lost it. I guess Jim and Dwight have settled on their prank and also on how they're going to get Todd
帕克弄走。是的，他们要假装从萨博公司打电话来。乔要为他提供一个在塔拉哈西的职位。是的。而且他到那儿就可以直接跳过栅栏。他们听起来太像他们自己了。哦，是的。我知道。就像他们本人一样。我只想指出，他们是在附属办公室的一部电话上打电话的。就像，显然托德根本不在乎。他听到了他需要听到的。他兴奋极了。是的。他说，你知道吗？最棒的是，他是个超级短吻鳄迷。他能说出每一个属和亚种。他也是个超级胸部迷。嗯，我们收到了来自佛罗里达州迈尔斯堡的杰拉尔德·T 的粉丝提问，安琪拉，他说，托德·帕克说他是个超级短吻鳄迷，能说出每一个属和每一个亚种。
Packer out of here. Yeah, they're going to pretend to be calling from Saber. Joe is going to offer him a position in Tallahassee. Yeah. And he can just hop the fence when he gets there. They sound exactly like themselves. Oh, yeah. I know. Like exactly like themselves. And I just want to point out they're calling from a phone in the annex. Like, it's clearly Todd doesn't care. He heard what he needed to hear. He's thrilled. Yeah. He says that, you know what? Best part, he's a huge alligator nerd. He can name every genus and subspecies. He's also a huge boob nerd. Well, we got a fan question from Gerald T. in Fort Myers, Florida, Angela, who said, Todd Packer says he's a huge alligator nerd and can name every genus and every subspecies.
但短吻鳄只有一个属。而且字面意思就叫短吻鳄。而且零短吻鳄亚种。杰拉尔德说，我很喜欢这句台词，以至于我在我主持的一个关于短吻鳄安全的演讲中使用了它。他还说，他愿意相信编剧们是故意开了这个玩笑，而且他们知道这会超出 99% 的观众的理解范围。嗯，杰拉尔德，你猜怎么着？这个托德·帕克单人访谈大约有一页半的糖果袋替代台词。他在所有台词里都是短吻鳄爱好者吗？在许多台词里是的。但也有一些是天马行空的。这里有一个我想分享的。托德·帕克。消息传得真快。显然，一旦总公司发现我
But there is only one alligator genus. And it's literally just called alligator. And there are zero alligator subspecies. Gerald said, I love this line so much that I use it in a presentation about alligator safety that I lead. He also said that he likes to believe that the writers intentionally made this joke and that they knew it would go way above the heads of 99% of the audience. Well, Gerald, guess what? There was about a page and a half of candy bag alts for this Todd Packer talking head. Was he an alligator enthusiast in all of them? And many of them. But there were also some that were all over the map. Here's one I thought I would share. Todd Packer. Word travels fast. Apparently, as soon as corporate found out I
想离开路面工作，乔就为我在塔拉哈西提供了一份舒适的新工作，在 hit that.com 上获得了四根丁丁向上的评分。那是整个半岛的约会中心。对不起，迈尔斯，四根丁丁向上。这是一个评分。迈尔斯太高兴其中一些东西最终留在了剪辑室的地板上了。你知道他对所有这些东西的评价吗？他给剪掉这些东西打了个 A 加。给你。我想也是。也许知道了他们剪掉了什么，分数会有所提高。 yeah. 迈克尔发现吉姆和德怀特在打这个电话。他对此很不高兴。他说他是我的朋友，我要告诉他真相。是的。所以在迈克尔的办公室里，托德和迈克尔正在进行一次亲切的交谈。托德在告诉他这个消息。他太兴奋了。但你知道吗？迈克尔在这个场景中
wanted to come in off the road, Joe offered me a cushy new job in Tallahassee, which got a four dongs up rating on the hit that.com. It's the hookup hub of the whole peninsula. Sorry, Miles, four dongs up. It's a rating. Miles is so happy that some of this stuff ended up on the cutting room floor. You know what he gives all that stuff? He gives it an A plus for cutting it out. There you go. I think so. Maybe it bumps the grade up knowing what they cut out. Yeah. Michael finds Jim and Dwight making this phone call. He's upset about it. He says he's my friend and I'm going to tell him the truth. Yeah. So in Michael's office, Todd and Michael are having a little heart to heart. Todd's telling him the news. He's so excited. But you know what? Michael in this scene
终于开始通过霍莉的眼睛和其他所有人的眼睛来看待托德·帕克了。他停了下来。他本来要告诉托德这是一个玩笑，然后他想，你知道吗？你应该去那里。这是迈克尔变得更加成熟、成为迎娶霍莉所需的那个男人的又一步。首先是通过不同的眼睛看他的电影，换个方式看《威胁午夜》，而现在他在换个方式看托德·帕克。在拍摄剧本中，这太棒了。霍莉和迈克尔谈论这件事的时刻，他们通过这些波士顿口音交流了大量的感情，比如，你才是，不，你才是。但上面写着霍莉充满感情地说“你才是”，包含了所有的潜台词。我喜欢那个。我知道。
finally starts to see Todd Packer through Holly's eyes and everyone else's. And he stops himself. He was going to tell Todd that it was a joke and then he's like, you know what? You should go down there. This was another step on the trail of Michael becoming more mature, becoming the man that he needs to be to marry Holly. First was seeing his movie through different eyes, seeing threat level midnight, another way. And now here he is seeing Todd Packer another way. In the shooting draft, it was so great. The moment when Holly and Michael talk about this and they're communicating so much through these Boston accents of like, you are, no, you are. But it said Holly says you are with emotion, all the subtext. I love that. I know.
帕克离开后，突然吉姆和帕姆旁边多了一个空桌子。在播出的那一集里，这没有被提及。但在拍摄剧本中，有一个关于这个的完整节拍，而且非常搞笑。不仅仅是德怀特搬回了他的桌子。不，不。吉姆向迈克尔恳求。哦天哪。是的。在拍摄剧本中，写着内景办公室，吉姆和德怀特的桌子群。迈克尔从他的办公室出来。他看着空桌子片刻，仿佛在想，曾经会怎样？迈克尔说，嗯，我不喜欢空桌子。谁想要这个？有人吗？吉姆跳了起来。这是他的时刻。他已经策划了好几年了。吉姆说，你知道吗？这里不需要有人。我们可以把它搬走。双人桌群，更少
After Packer leaves, all of a sudden there's an empty desk next to Jim and Pam. In the episode that aired, it's not addressed. But in the shooting draft, there was a whole beat about this and it was really funny. It isn't just that Dwight moves back to his desk. No, no. Jim makes a plea to Michael. Oh my gosh. Yeah. In the shooting draft, it said interior office, Jim and Dwight's desk clump. Michael comes out of his office. He looks at the empty desk for a moment like, what could have been? Michael says, well, I don't like an empty desk. Who wants this? Anyone? Jim jumps up. This is his moment. He's been planning for years. Jim says, you know what? No one needs to be here. We could get rid of it. Two person clump, less
干扰，更多步行空间，供你表演的小舞台。迈克尔说，也许吧。德怀特开始穿过厨房。吉姆看到他，变得更加焦虑。吉姆对迈克尔说。做吧。你可以做到。求求你，求求你。我从没向你要求过什么。德怀特进来了。德怀特说，我的桌子。迈克尔说，哦，对，你应该搬回这里。吉姆说，该死。德怀特给了迈克尔一个大大的拥抱。帕姆说，没关系，亲爱的。我告诉过你，不要让自己相信这会发生。德怀特吻了他的桌子。这有点甜蜜。然后他拿出一把大刀，立刻开始在桌子上刻自己的名字。迈克尔说，很高兴你回来。吉姆曾有过他的时刻，但它没有发生。嗯，听着，帕姆和安迪设法把
distractions, more walking space, a little stage for you to perform in. Michael says, maybe Dwight starts walking through the kitchen. Jim sees him and gets more anxious. Jim says to Michael, do this. You can do this. Please, please. I never ask anything of you. Dwight enters. Dwight says, my desk. Michael says, oh yeah, you should move back here. Jim goes, damn it. Dwight gives Michael a huge hug. Pam says, it's okay, honey. I told you not to let yourself believe it could happen. Dwight kisses his desk. It's kind of sweet. And then he takes out a large knife and starts immediately carving his own name into the desk. Michael says, glad you're back. Jim had his moment, but it didn't happen. Well, listen, Pam and Andy managed to destroy
安迪的电脑破坏得够呛。哦，是的，他们往里面塞了各种东西。博洛尼亚香肠、芥末、划得稀烂。是的。而且她已经换了一台。但随后他们得把新电脑弄得有点划痕，这样她才能让大家相信她是随手在仓库的一个架子上找到的。这让达里尔竖起了耳朵。他像是，你在仓库里找到的，啊？是的。所以达里尔在休息室接近了帕姆。他要拆穿这种鬼话。他绝对会的。我称休息室里的这个场景为胡扯。他说也许她应该回到那个地方去，在某个架子上给他找几个额外的病假天数。太荒谬了。你知道吗？她确实记得在架子上看到过病假天数。五个。是的，达里尔记得有五个。帕姆说三个。成交。我们收到了一个粉丝提问，
Andy's computer enough. Oh yeah, they put all kinds of stuff in it. Bologna, mustard, scratched it up. Yes. And she has replaced it. But then they have to kind of scuff up the new one so that she can convince everyone that she found it on a shelf in the warehouse somewhere. This makes Daryl's ears perk up. He's like, you found it in the warehouse, huh? Yeah. So Daryl approaches Pam in the break room. He's going to call bullshit on that. He sure is. I'm calling this scene bullshit in the break room. He says maybe she should go back down there and find him some extra sick days on a shelf somewhere. Scandalous. And you know what? She does remember seeing a sick day on the shelf. Five. Yeah, Daryl remembers five. Pam says three. Agreed. We had a fan question
来自北卡罗来纳州的阿曼达·A，她说在尾声中，当达里尔问帕姆她是否能给他找一些额外的病假天数时，这会是怎么运作的？这真的是帕姆能控制的事情吗？显然，帕姆拥有的控制权比我们想象的要多得多。她能弄到电脑。她能篡改系统。这就是我要说的。在她拥有这份工作之前，是谁负责这一切的？谁干的？这本该是迈克尔的活吗？是的。这些是她以前作为前台接待员时顺便做的，而迈克尔只会顺手签个字吗？我想她做了很多迈克尔的工作，所以她知道如何操纵系统。我是这么想的。你知道，在最后的单人访谈中，帕姆说她彻底腐败了。而且她对此感到很高兴。但我的问题是，
from Amanda A. in North Carolina who said in the tag when Daryl asked Pam if she can find him some extra sick days, how would this work? Is this really something Pam would have control over? Apparently Pam has a lot more control than we could ever imagine. She can get computers. She can fudge the system. That's what I'm saying. Who was in charge of all of this before she had this job? Who did this? Was it supposed to be Michael? Yes. Is this stuff that she used to do as the receptionist and Michael would just kind of sign off on it? I think she did a lot of Michael's job and so she knew how to manipulate the system. That's what I think. You know, in her final talking head, Pam says she's full on corrupt. And she's delighted by it. But here's my question.
帕姆从这笔交易中得到了什么？她为什么腐败了？她得到了什么？我知道她操纵了系统，但那是为了安迪好。然后我想她腐败是因为她通过给另一个人谋取好处来掩盖她所做的事情。我不明白这对帕姆有什么好处。她得到了掌控权。权力冲昏了她的头脑。现在她成了掩盖真相的一员。我想就是这样吧。嗯，伙计们，这就是托德·帕克。我们希望你们喜欢。也许给自己弄点泰滋蛋糕。我们确实喜欢它们，或者也许买个蚁场。是的，或者去给自己买一件正义海狸的衬衫。我们下周将带着“车库大甩卖”回归。哦天哪。我们有很多关于那一集的内容要分享。祝大家有个愉快的一周。在我们结束时我有些东西要送给你们。哦，是什么？
What is Pam getting out of this deal? Why is she corrupt? What did she get? I know she manipulated the system, but it was in Andy's favor. And then I guess she's corrupt because she's covering up what she did by giving a favor to another person. I'm not understanding what's in it for Pam. She gets to hold power. The power has gone to her head. And now she's part of a cover-up. I guess that's what it is. Well, guys, that was Todd Packer. We hope you enjoyed. Maybe get yourself some tasty cakes. We sure like them or maybe an ant farm. Yeah, or go buy yourself a Justice Beaver shirt. We will be back next week with Garage Sale. Oh my goodness. We have a lot to share about that one. Have a great week, you guys. And I have something for you guys as we go. Oh, what is it?
这是什么？这是《油脂 2》里的保龄球馆歌曲，安琪拉。我没看过这个。这首歌叫 Score Tonight。没错。你懂了吗？这是一语双关。这首歌值得四个丁丁向上。确实如此。感谢收听“办公室女士”。“办公室女士”由 Earwolf、珍娜·费舍尔和安琪拉·金西联合制作。我们的执行制片人是科迪·费舍尔。我们的制作人是卡西·杰金斯。我们的音响工程师是萨姆·基弗。我们的副制作人是艾恩斯利·布比科。我们的主题曲是克里德·布拉顿的《Rubber Tree》。要收听无广告版本的“办公室女士”，请访问 StitcherPremium.com。要获得 Stitcher Premium 的一个月免费试用，请使用代码 OFFICE。这一集还没有评论。点击字幕中的任意句子即可发表评论。
What is this? It's the bowling alley song from Grease 2, Angela. I have not seen this. The song is called Score Tonight. That's right. Do you get it? It's a double on tall draw. This gets four dongs up. It sure does. Thank you for listening to Office Ladies. Office Ladies is produced by Earwolf, Jenna Fisher, and Angela Kinsey. Our show is executive produced by Cody Fisher. Our producer is Cassie Jerkins. Our sound engineer is Sam Kiefer. And our associate producer is Ainsley Bubbicoe. Our theme song is Rubber Tree by Creed Bratton. For ad-free versions of Office Ladies, go to StitcherPremium.com. For a free one-month trial of Stitcher Premium, use code, OFFICE. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
这是什么？这是《油脂2》里的保龄球馆之歌，安吉拉。我没看过这个。这首歌叫《今晚得分》。没错。你懂了吗？这是一个双人高脚平局。这个得四个铜锣。确实如此。感谢收听《办公室女士》。《办公室女士》由Earwolf、詹娜·费舍尔和安吉拉·金西制作。我们的节目执行制片人是科迪·费舍尔。我们的制作人是卡西·杰金斯。我们的音响工程师是萨姆·基弗。我们的助理制作人是艾因斯利·巴比科。我们的主题曲是克里德·布拉顿的《橡胶树》。有关《办公室女士》的无广告版本，请访问StitcherPremium.com。有关Stitcher Premium的一个月免费试用，请使用代码OFFICE。本集尚无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。